pas bonjour à toutes et à tous avec
philippe juvin vous accueillir pour ce
nouveau point presse des républicains
nous souhaitons dans un premier temps
vous passez un petit film retraçant les
mois les semaines et l'ensemble des
réunions qui nous ont permis de
présenter un dispositif de
reconstruction qui aujourd'hui avec
l'appui des militants des votes qui ont
été faites mais également de toutes les
réunions propose un certain nombre
d'éléments nous souhaitons d'ailleurs le
mettre en parallèle ce travail de
terrain fort dans les territoires avec
ce qui se passe aujourd'hui avec la
république en marche qui va désigner par
la main du prince et bien son leader
samedi prochain sommes un petit peu
étonné que dans une des plus grandes
démocraties du monde
là où l'article 5 de la constitution
indique que les partis politiques
concourent à l'expression du suffrage du
peuple et bien
ce soit un homme même s'il est président
de la république qui décide de devenir
d'un parti tout ça nous sommes pas très
moderne
pas très en phase avec ce que souhaitent
certainement nos concitoyens d'autant
plus que ce parti qui revendique 300
mille adhérents mais si on écoute ses
cadres qui n'en n'a en réalité que
100000 actif n'a pas de représentation
territoriale n'a pas de réalité deux
groupes un groupe parlementaire à
l'assemblée nationale qui est largement
caporaliser qui n'a pas le droit de
s'exprimer les pauvres n'ont même pas le
droit de faire des amendements
quitte à se faire taper dessus par leur
chef
la seule découverte en fait de ce qui va
se passer samedi c'est que la réalité
des cadres ceux partis --socialistes
puisque si on en prend la liste
messieurs castaner tueur secrétaire
général monsieur griveaux messieurs
ferrand monsieur leroy sont tous
d'anciens membres du parti socialiste
donc il y as somme toute une information
à en marche en marche ce socialisme ce
que je vous propose maintenant c'est
peut-être de passer
le petit film 1
[Musique]
vous avez dit la droite libérale et
gaullistes le progress d'éternité faut
qu'on trouve la bonne façon d'un lancer
du revers
voilà merci aux militants qui se sont
beaucoup investis merci aux cadres du
parti merci à bernard acoyer qui a donné
énormément pour ce dispositif et on le
voit sur les valeurs qui sont les nôtres
et qui sont clairement ancrés bien ce
parti va pouvoir au travers d'une
élection qui elle est ouverte qui elle
est démocratique qui elle s'adresse à
ses militants qui ont adhéré se choisir
son nouveau sa nouvelle présidente
et c'est sans doute ça la première
promesse de la droite c'est de ne pas
voler à nos adhérents leur élection est
somme toute on a un peu l'impression que
c'est ce qui se passe avec en marche
puisqu'il ya déjà quelques petites notes
dissonantes qui se font entendre mais
c'est de permettre à nos adhérents de se
choisir et bien leur ligne et le leader
qui pourra incarner ça se passe les 10
et 17 décembre
et nous sommes heureux de pouvoir y
participer chacun à notre niveau
premier point que nous souhaitons mettre
à l'ordre du jour de ce point presse
nous sommes à six mois de l'élection de
monsieur macron la presse s'en fait
l'écho avec un certain nombre de
sondages d'opinion si on les regarde
chacun on se rencontre que un peu plus
de 65% des français n'y trouvent pas
leur compte et danser 65% de français
qui ne trouvent pas leur compte
beaucoup se sentent en fait victime de
ses premiers mois de mandature
macron qui sont ils la france qui
travaille pas la france du cac 40 non la
france qui travaille les classes
moyennes et la france qui a beaucoup
travaillé et qui a donné à ce pays qui
lui a permis d'être ce qu'il est
aujourd'hui c'est à dire les retraités
si on regarde les décisions qui ont été
prises et contre lesquels nous avons
combattu et contre lesquels nous
continuerons à dénoncer
on voit très bien que les 25 points de
csg en plus c'est profondément injuste
et ça va faire beaucoup
victimes dans notre pays on voit très
bien que la baisse du cic eux ce n'est
pas une bonne nouvelle
pourquoi parce que ça va augmenter le
coût du travail et qui va en être
victime
eh bien ceux qui n'ont effectivement que
ce travail qui est une valeur importante
pour leur permettre de maintenir un
niveau de vie
on voit aussi que l'épisode sur réaliste
de la surtaxe à 3% sur les entreprises
qui va nous coûter quand même 10
milliards d'euros va forcément et
mécaniquement avoir un retour de bâton
sur un renchérissement du coût du
travail
tous ces éléments même s'ils sont
d'inégalé valeur nous montrent en fait
que les personnes qui font vivre ce pays
tout au long de l'année et bien ne sont
pas écoutés par ce gouvernement
elles ne sont pas entendus et ce n'est
pas un déplacement en banlieue qui va
permettre de rétablir ce lien et cette
écoute
d'autant plus que ce déplacement il a
vocation à dire quoi à dire que on a
supprimé les contrats aidés mais qu'on
les remplace par des contrats france pas
trop ce qu'il y a derrière nous allons
le voir aujourd'hui la réalité néanmoins
c'est que les financements pour les
contrats aidés et la droite a toujours
dénoncé le fait d'avoir mis beaucoup
trop de contrats aidés a été fait
quid aujourd'hui des personnes
handicapées qui bénéficié des contrats
aidés
quid des personnes qui avaient
réellement une nécessité d'être
accompagnés sur ces dispositifs est ce
que ces contrats francs vont s'adresser
notamment aux personnes les plus
fragiles de notre société
on est dans la semaine de l'emploi des
personnes handicapées je le rappelle
j'attends toujours des annonces et nous
attendons toujours des annonces en la
matière autre point sur les banlieues et
cette france périurbaines qui méconnaît
particulièrement le président de la
république son prédécesseur avec lequel
il a collaboré et avec lequel il a
beaucoup travaillé avait promis 5
milliards d'euros pour les banlieues on
n'a jamais vu le début d'un centime lui
même
double la mise vous allez me dire zéro
plus zéro ça fait toujours zéro en en
premier temps 10 là il faut arrêter de
promettre de l'argent il faut mettre en
place une réalité des dispositifs que
va-t-il réellement se placer dans les
banlieues sur la rénovation urbaine
combien de quartier combien de
démolition combien de reconstruction
combien de logements et c'est pas avec
la politique de logement qui vient de
nous être annoncé on va reconstruire
dans les banlieues donc aujourd'hui je
pense qu'il faut arrêter la
communication et il faut rentrer dans
l'ère de la proposition de la réalité
des faits la réalité des faits c'est le
projet de loi de finances la réalité des
faits c'est de l'argent qui est inscrit
et qui est réellement mis en perspective
or nous en sommes malheureusement très
loin dernier point est un point majeur
puisqu'il se dessine autour des six mois
de la gouvernance du président macron
c'est une fracture territoriale qui ne
fait que s'aggraver
la volonté aujourd'hui du gouvernement
de tours centralisée de tout décider à
paris de faire en sorte que quelques
fonctionnaires puisqu'il ne s'agit même
pas d'élu mais quelques fonctionnaires
puissent avoir l'intégralité des
manettes nous rappelle une autre époque
mais c'était une époque qui est tête
avant celle de la république une époque
où des rois régnait et dans des cabinets
décider de ce qu'ils allaient faire de
leur province
la réforme de la formation
professionnelle qui nous est annoncé
pour le printemps avec la volonté de
reprendre des compétences qui sont
aujourd'hui des compétences générales
qui appartient aux régions démontre
cette volonté est bien de revenir sur un
pacte républicain qui celui-là
décentralisation et ce pacte fondateur
est clairement plébiscité par les
français
donc on voit que au travers de six mois
d'action
il y a à la fois plus des deux tiers des
français qui se trouvent et qui se
disent réellement victime d'une action
sur laquelle ne se retrouvent pas sont
principalement les français qui
travaillent et qui ne peuvent pas
pensez pouvoir vivre mieux des fruits de
ce travail et ça nous la droite et le
centre ne pouvons pas l'accepter
et c'est les français qui ne sont pas et
bien dans le giron de la haute
administration qui décide et qui
aujourd'hui a clairement pris la main
sur le pouvoir
il s'agit pour nous de le dénoncer avec
force ce n'est pas ça le pacte
républicain et ce n'est pas ça la
démocratie
merci avant de d'évoquer les questions
européennes juste je reviens sur le
propos que tu tenais parce que on a
l'impression que le gouvernement en fait
ouvre des petites cases de calendrier de
l'avent
chaque jour il fait semblant de
découvrir quelque chose qu'ils
n'auraient pas vu avant
alors que nous nous et tous les
commentateurs l'avez vu on a eu le
prélèvement à la source qui brutalement
est devenue une affaire très compliquée
à mettre en oeuvre
on a eu l'insas hérité du budget qui
brutalement après l'élection au premier
ministre a commencé à dire ah mais le
budget finalement il est insincère alors
que nous le disions depuis un an
souvenez-vous même touraine qui nous
disait l'assurance sociale l'assurance
maladie est sauvé c'était il ya un an et
on voit dans quelles conditions on est
on le voit sur la taxe sur les
dividendes des fameux 10 milliards enfin
cette affaire je me suis posé une
question tout à l'heure kerviel s'était
combien 4,5 milliards là on est à 10
milliards et personne ne semble
s'émouvoir de cette affaire et personne
n'est responsable
le scandale d'état dont parlait mise des
finances il est évident et c'était et on
le savait et on nous l'avions dit
auparavant la question de nicolas hulot
qui semble découvrir que ce que nous
disons depuis le vote de la loi sur les
transitions énergétiques pour lui
apparaissent dire qu'il a dit qu'en 2025
on ne pourra pas être 50 % de l'énergie
par centrale nucléaire mais nous nous le
disons depuis le début
et là aussi c'est une nouvelle petite
case du calendrier de l'avent qui
s'ouvre et il fait semblant de découvrir
ça nous ce que nous disons c'est que
nous voulons sortir du charbon c'est ça
la priorité pour la santé et nous disent
ah mais oui mais on voulait commencer
par supprimer les centrales nucléaires
mais on sait pas par quoi les remplacer
regardez ce qui se passe en allemagne où
la situation était vide
en théorie puisque c'est le premier
producteur européen de co2 par tête
d'habitant
et puis il ya le budget militaire là
aussi nous disions qu'il était sincère
on nous dit non non il n'est pas sincère
tout va bien et maintenant ils nous
disent oui il était sincère à tel point
qu'on a supprimé 850 millions d'euros de
budget ce qui a provoqué vous souvenez
le drame d'avant d'avant les vacances
puis enfin il est à faire des des
retraites ton premier ministre nous dit
pendant des mois qu'ils toucheront à
rien ils ne changeront ni la durée de
cotisation ni le prélèvement
nous disons que c'est pas possible
mathématiquement on nous dit qu'on n'a
rien compris
et puis aujourd'hui on commence à nous
raconter que peut-être il va falloir
faire quelque chose et donc ce que nous
dénonçons nous ici c'est une sorte de
mauvaise cette palme d'or c'est une
mauvaise foi du gouvernement qui sait
très bien où sur les difficultés mais
qu'il 'n'y jusqu'au moment où un peu
plus les nier et nous eh bien nous
sommes comme ce qui est annonçons des
mauvaises nouvelles très en avance pour
pouvoir les régler en temps mais le
temps qui passe rend impossible le
gouvernement à régler ces questions
alors sur les questions européennes
d'abord nous sommes début novembre
hier c'était l'anniversaire du 13
novembre évidemment les républicains
considèrent que c'est une date
extrêmement importante la france est
passée dans une autre ère ya deux ans
nous sommes très inquiets de la présence
d'un nombre important de djihadistes
revenus du levant sur notre territoire
les chiffres varient selon les
interlocuteurs probablement 150 à 200
actuellement et peut-être plus est en
tout cas 450 à 650 qui pourrait revenir
selon les chiffres du ministère de
l'intérieur
donc nous sommes extrêmement inquiets
est ce que nous pensons c'est que ces
gens-là doivent être jugés ils doivent
tous être jugé et quand ils sont eux le
vent en irak ou en syrie doivent être
jugés en irak ou en syrie la france n'a
pas à leur verser des cotisations
sociales ou quand il sera là bas marche
sur la tête quand même dans cette
affaire et l'idée de penser qu'il
revienne sur notre territoire en ayant
changé d'avis et tout simplement une
plaisanterie sinistre mais une
plaisanterie comment voulez vous que ces
gens soit allé en syrie sens sans savoir
ce qui s'y passait tout le monde sait ce
qui s'y passe youtube est envahi de
vidéos épouvantable où on voit des gens
se faire décapiter projetée du haut
d'immeubles etc etc et on veut nous dire
qu'aujourd'hui ils se sont rendus compte
les pauvres chéris sur place et du coup
maintenant il regrette en fait ils
savaient et simplement ils reviennent
parce qu'ils ont été battus et ce que
nous voulons nous c'est que tous ces
gens il ya aucun d'entre eux ne soient
en liberté ce n'est pas le cas
aujourd'hui nous sommes très inquiets
deuxième question c'est les élections
européennes eu un débat sur faut-il
modifier le mode de scrutin aux
élections européennes nous considérons
qu'il est inimaginable que dans une
démocratie moderne matures comme devrait
l'être la france on puisse avoir même
l'idée de changer le mode de scrutin
parce que ça arrange
y a que chez nous que ça se voit il
suffit qu'un gouvernement pense qu'il va
perdre les élections et il modifie le
mode de scrutin on l'a vu avec les
socialistes qui ont créé la métropole du
grand paris ont changé le mode
d'élection conseil régional et c'est ce
qu'il faut savoir le tripatouillage ça
ne paye jamais
l'intervention chirurgicale se traduit
toujours par une autopsie en matière
électorale
donc il faut savoir s'ils veulent aller
jusqu'à l'auto psy c'est ça le sujet
donc nous dénonçons le tripatouillage
électoral puis un deuxième sujet la
fameuse liste unique des européens
qu'ils s'opposeraient aux anti européen
c'est la voie ouverte à marine le pen et
mélenchon si on veut jouer le boulevard
aux anti européen est en fait joué
contre l'europe il faut surtout faire le
parti unique nous ne voulons pas du
parti unique croyons dans les
démocraties la dispute intellectuelle la
bagarre sur les projets c'est quelque
chose de sain et nécessaire
et l'idée qu'on puisse faire une liste
unique après a plus un tripatouillage
électoral nous semble tout ce qu'il faut
pas faire en matière d'exercice
démocratique
troisième point sur le déficit excessif
vous savez que la france est avec
l'espagne le seul pays dans une
situation de déclaration dit de déficit
excessif c'est là c'est le terme qu'on
utilise en europe
on pourrait en sortir l'année prochaine
il suffit qu'un pays
enfin il suffit qu'un pays soit au
dessous de 3% de déficit deux années
successives successives le gouvernement
a commencé à dire qu'on serait à 2,6 la
commission européenne leur a dit non
vous serez à 2,9 et honnêtement entre 2
9 et 3
je pense qu'il faut vraiment s'appeler
pierre moscovici et vouloir vraiment se
faire re nommé commissaire européen par
emmanuel macron dans deux ans pour être
aussi sympa sur le commentaire on voit
très bien que la commission européenne
via pierre moscovici joue un rôle qui
est un peu curieux surinterprétation de
chiffres
il reste pas moins que si on arrive à
2,9 on sera ravi une loi républicain
voilà c'est notre pays sort de la
procédure mais je rappelle simplement un
chiffre c'est que s'il faut pas en faire
un cocorico la moyenne des déficits de
la zone euro c'est 1,1 l'année prochaine
1,1 pour cent et nous avec notre 2009 on
allait dire c'est formidable on a passé
l'obstacle
c'est comme ces gens qui passent
l'obstacle en touchant la barre qui
oscille et il passe pas c'est pas très
glorieux pour la france donc cette
situation de toute façon reste
extrêmement préoccupante
enfin dernier peut-être sujet il y en
aura d'autres ce que voudrait aborder
c'est la question des paradis fiscaux
vous savez qu'il ya un grand débat
aujourd'hui sur les par dice paper
qu'est ce que nous avons à dire nous
avons à en dire que d'abord il faut pas
confondre la triche fiscal de
l'optimisation fiscale l'optimisation
elle n'est malheureusement que la
conséquence de politiques fiscales qui
sont inadaptées quand on a une politique
fiscale qui consiste à tuer les
entreprises comme on l'a eue depuis cinq
ans en france
eh bien il faut pas s'étonner quand
suite des gens veuillent s'échapper de
la prison
donc ça c'est le premier point et puis
derrière qu'est ce qu'il faut faire
ben oui je pense qu'il faut qu'on ait
vraiment une réflexion politique et une
action politique
le ministère de la parole sur c'est pas
bien
l'évasion fiscale ça suffit pas et le
gouvernement aujourd'hui fait de
l'incantation je ne sais pas où sont ces
propositions nous nos propositions elles
sont très claires et elles existent
d'abord nous voulons premièrement une
publication de la liste noire des
paradis fiscaux
cette liste elle existe elle est sur la
table du conseil
depuis un an et les états dont la france
ne veulent pas l'adopter donc il faut
pas nous faire nous la faire à l'envers
si je peux parler très très très
vulgairement avec d'un côté un discours
qui en france ferait que les ministres
demanderait la publication d'une liste
noire mais la refuserait en europe
elle existe cette liste il faut
l'adopter ça c'est la première demande
des républicains
la deuxième demande c'est que la
conséquence c'est que nous voulons que
les pays qui soit inscrit sur cette
liste noire de plus plus du tout
bénéficié de fonds européens ou de fonds
donnés par des structures perry
européenne je pense à la banque centrale
européenne par exemple ce n'est plus
possible il faut que ces pays sur la
liste noire soit à la diète budgétaire
européenne troisième proposition des
républicains
un certain nombre de cabinets d'avocats
au monté des opérations très complexe
d'optimisation fiscale c'est ce qui est
dénoncé par un certain nombre de gens
ils font leur travail
ce que nous voulons simplement puisque
ce n'est pas illégal c'est pas
l'interdire puisque ce n'est pas illégal
ça serait absurde mais que toutes les
opérations très complexe fiscal soit
déclarée à l'administration fiscale qu'
il y ait de la transparence dans cette
affaire n'ont pas rendu public
secret des affaires mais déclarée à
l'administration fiscale
et enfin quatrième point il existe
depuis deux ans en europe
ce qu'on appelle un échange pays par
perry d'informations fiscales c'est à
dire que les pays européens doivent
mutuellement s'informer des
optimisations fiscales qui l'autorisent
c'est suite à la sphère du luxembourg
qui avait optimiser un certain nombre de
rescrit fiscaux c'est très bien ça
existe mais ça ne suffit pas et les
républicains nous nous demandons que
pour le coup ces échanges de données
fiscales pays par pays soit rendue
publique la transparence
ça permet de lutter contre l'évasion
fiscale voilà nous nous sommes dans le
concret nous faisons des propositions et
nous sommes pas en train de
sautez sur la table comme un cabri en
disant l'optimisation fiscale
l'optimisation fiscale
la politique c'est aussi prendre ses
responsabilités voilà sur les questions
les principales questions d'ordre
européenne mais valérie moi même sont
évidemment à votre disposition pour
répondre à d'autres questions
oui bon joueur or en matière européenne
les élus de votre parti qui ont des
idées plus proche c'est de les manuels
macron que de celle du futur président
est ce qu'ils ont toujours leur place au
sein de votre parti
en fait je ne sais pas ce que ça veut
dire moi je suis je suis député européen
je crois que la france a besoin d'un
véhicule de puissance c'est à dire que
notre pays a éclairé le monde plusieurs
fois dans son histoire
et si nous voulons continuer à
l'éclairer il faut que nous puissions
peut compter sur un véhicule de
puissance en cela je suis un europhile
convaincu parce que c'est l'intérêt de
la france
autrement dit je suis européen parce que
je suis patriote et ça c'est une ligne
qui est tenu aux républicains c'est
notre ligne depuis toujours
moi je vous rappelle que c'est notre
famille politique qui étaient aux
affaires
quand la france la dernière fois présidé
le conseil et ça a été une des
présidences les plus efficaces et
flamboyante et reconnu donc l'idée de
dire l'europe c'est macron c'est une
arnaque intellectuelle
nous sommes aussi européens s'y être
européen cette considérer que la france
doit faire partie d'un ensemble plus
large partager des valeurs un projet de
civilisation c'est aussi l'europe
nous sommes profondément européen il n'y
a pas de parti unique européen voyez
c'est pas parce que j'ai fait un beau
discours je m'appelle mais une manuelle
macron sur l'europe et j'applaudis à son
discours c'était un beau discours sur
l'europe mais ça ne suffit pas la
question c'est qu'est-ce qu'on fait
derrière et quand on creuse un peu et
parfois des journalistes creuse et
parfois ne creuse pas si vous me
permettez mai et qu'on regarde le détail
qu'est ce qui s'est passé depuis six
mois en europe
le président et le premier ministre nous
ont mis mal avec les italiens sur la
sphère de filton thierry les chantiers
valve nous ont mis mal avec les polonais
sur l' affaire d'état de droit nous ont
mis mal avec les allemands fallait le
faire sur la question des eurobonds
qu'ils ont déclaré nécessaires ainsi que
le budget européen soit 1000 yards
emmanuel macron pendant la campagne des
élections législatives allemandes
autant dire ça a été un repoussoir
terrible sur les travailleurs détachés
moi j'ai été frappé par les commentaires
qui disaient emmanuel macron a sauvé la
directive travailleurs détachés mais
pardon ça faisait deux ans qu'on y
travaille à la réalité elle est la
suivante je vais vous l'expliquer quand
ils arrivent au pouvoir au mois de juin
la directive elle est prête à la
révision que vous allez que vous avez vu
il ya quelques semaines c'était près un
mois de jeu que fait manuel macron il
dit ah mais ça ne va pas il faut
repousser en automne parce que j'exige
que les les cotisations sociales soit
incluse dans la révision sauf que les
cotisations sociales peuvent pas être
incluses parce qu'il s'agit d'un
deuxième texte qu'on appelle le
règlement sécurité sociale il appose
sens la conséquence c'est qu'on se
retrouve à devoir adopter en octobre en
catastrophe ce qu'on avait prévu
d'adopter en juin jeudi en catastrophe
pourquoi parce que si on avait perdu un
mois on se retrouvait le 1er janvier et
le 1er janvier vous savez qui dirige
l'union européenne c'est la bulgarie et
les bulgares
il n'était pas très favorable à la
révision de la directive et donc c'est
très bien de tenir de beaux discours
mais en pratique quand vous creusez un
peu et vous apercevez que sorte
d'arrogance une sorte de certitudes pose
un vrai problème en europe et
aujourd'hui les gens
se pose la question de savoir quelle va
être la place de la france parce que
c'est pas parce que les britanniques ont
disparu pour être puissants
on sera plus puissant et on comptera
plus que ce soit hollande ce qui est
facile si le élément de comparaison
c'est souvent non avait disparu ça c'est
certain
et bien la vacation c'est pour peser en
europe il faut bien s'entendre avec ses
partenaires et en six mois il nous a mis
mal avec trois grands pays ce qui est un
vrai un vrai souci donc pardon je moi je
refuse d'entendre que si on est européen
on aime acronis non moi je suis
profondément européen
j'ai même écrit un livre qui s'appelle
la nation européenne je veux dire je en
d'autres temps j'aurais probablement été
brûlés par des gens qui ne veulent pas
l'europe
ça montre bien que nous sommes certes
parfois différent sur l'europe mais
parce que républicain c'est pas une
caserne de marche
on n'est pas tous du même avis sur tout
et en plus il se trouve qu'on demande
d'avis aux gens républicain c'est ça la
difficulté
alors quand marché lisez vite moins on
voit pas les différences donc nous
sommes profondément européen mais nous
disons que l'europe a besoin aussi de
débat est l'idée qui est une liste
unique et ben c'est la certitude que là
il y aura près de débats et marine le
pen
vous verrez le score qu'elle fera si on
joue à ce genre de did you see et après
que deviendra l'europe ce que c'est
facile de faire des petits débats
français mais si derrière l'affluence
française en souffrent pascal en
souffrira et et simplement les
eurosceptiques sont plus nombreux au
parlement européen ne faudra pas venir
nous dire qu'on regrette je vais plus
précis sur la question alors est ce que
pour regretter ce genre de propos d'un
ancien premier ministre alain juppé qui
félicitent au milieu de journalistes
l'attitude de monsieur macron vis-à-vis
de l'europe
non non non en fait moi je d'abord je
note qu'on a fait porter à alain juppé
le chapeau d'une déclaration qui n'a pas
déclaré alain juppé on a dit de lui je
crois samedi qu'il souhaitait une liste
unique et il a dit lui-même que c'était
faux donc les choses sont claires
tout simplement parce qu'alain juppé qui
est un fin politique c'est s'il ya une
liste unique c'est la porte ouverte à
marine le pen et mélenchon
deuxièmement qu'on dise que le président
de la république a fait un beau discours
sur l'europe mais je suis le premier à
le dire je voulais dire
je porte parole europe et rémy lucas je
viens de vous dire que le président
avait fait un beau discours sur l'europe
mais je vous ai dit aussi que
malheureusement les discours ça suffit
pas et que derrière il faut des paroles
il faut des actes et qu'il se trouve que
les actes ont plutôt était en
contradiction avec une volonté de voir
la france faisait en europe peut-être
par maladresse peut-être par ignorance
des circuits de décision peut-être par
un caractère qui croient que tout le
monde va suivre
mais il se trouve que en france on a une
toute puissance du président de la
république c'est quasi institutionnel
mais en europe ça n'est pas comme ça il
faut travailler avec les autres donc non
je ne je ne regrette pas que alain juppé
et dit qu'il trouvait que le discours du
président était bon c'est un bon
discours mais encore une fois ça suffit
pas ce qu'on constate aussi à droite
c'est vous vous dites toujours très
europhile et d'ailleurs c'est dans la
charte des valeurs du parti
l'attachement aux valeurs européennes
deux du parti les républicains et des
propos de tribunes de plus en plus
eurosceptique
on constate à travers les campagnes
électorales des propos très critiques
sur la commission sur l'europe passoire
au niveau de l'immigration ou des livres
comme en 2014 d'une monsieur wauquiez
l'europe tout doit changer et c'est où
il y avait vraiment des termes très durs
à l'égard de l'union européenne même à
une réduction l'union européenne à six
pays dont on se demande si vous n'êtes
pas proclamer une europhilie qui est en
fait des propos de tribunes très
eurosceptique est un parti de plus en
plus eurosceptique et c'est ça qui
alimente peut-être ce clivage entre une
partie de la droite modérée et une
droite plus dur comme on en fait ce que
nous disons est assez simple c'est que
l'europe a un vrai problème de
fonctionnement et l'europe souvent
proclame d intention d'agir mais n'agit
pas parce que sa gouvernance est
complexe
regardez la sphère du pnr passenger name
record d'heures vous savez ce fichier
des voyageurs qu'on a adopté sa a été
mis sur la table en 2011
on l'a adoptée en 2016 cinq ans pour
adopter une législation européenne alors
qu'il ya une urgence sécuritaire ce que
nous disons républicain est simple nous
pensons qu'il faut une europe avec
laquelle nous pouvons espérer compter
encore
dans l'avenir et donc nous fuyons tous
les discours qui met en danger
cette architecture mais nous disons
aussi que l'europe aujourd'hui
fonctionne mal il ya un problème de
gouvernance
il ya un problème de lenteur de prise de
décision il ya un problème de lisibilité
démocratique et vous savez ce que je dis
monsieur juncker président de la
commission européenne l'a dit dans son
discours de l'union au mois d'octobre
devant le parlement européen à
strasbourg
il a dit la même chose il a même fait
une proposition que si nous l'avions
fait nouveau certains pas vous bien sûr
aurait dit regardez vous remettez en
cause l'europe
juncker a fait la proposition que le
président du conseil devienne le
président de la commission ainsi pro
comment c'est une révolution ce qui
montre bien qu'il ya un vrai problème de
gouvernance
nous sommes 28 comme il ya vingt-huit
commissaire autour de la table la
lituanie la france l'allemagne et malte
ont un commissaire européen nous posons
la question est ce qu'à l'avenir il ne
faut pas se poser la question du nombre
de commissaires autour de la table on
avait prévu une époque
et puis on l'a abandonnée par faiblesse
est ce que il est illogique de penser
que le président du conseil soit élu
selon un modèle plus démocratique
directe
ce serait pas mal de réfléchir à une
telle évolution des choses
donc nous voulons que l'europe soit plus
efficace et pour qu'elle soit plus
efficace il faut probablement qu'elle
soit à cercles concentriques non pas à
mettre les gens dehors mais je pense
qu'il ya des pays qui ont décidé de
travailler plus ensemble que d'autres
c'est le cas il ya les pays quand l'euro
d'autres qui n'ont pas par exemple
pendant que cet exemple nous pensons
qu'il faut une europe beaucoup plus
intégrée sur un noyau dur l'énergie la
monnaie probablement la politique
industrielle de défense le climat
probablement les politiques fiscales et
une zone une zone plus large qui sont
qui est l'actuelle union européenne en
gros c'est le marché unique
c'est ça l'avenir de l'europe est là
dessus vous mettez une couche de
gouvernance qui est plus efficace plus
rapide plus capable de prendre des
décisions
notre famille politique a toujours
travaillé à cette question de
gouvernance quand sarkozy président de
la république il devient président du
conseil et à l'époque il découvre à
l'occasion de la crise en géorgie que le
conseil se réunit une à deux fois par
trimestre par semestre
une à deux fois comment voulez vous que
ça marche et c'est lui qui à l'époque
dit c'est pas possible il faut se voir
plus souvent ils reconvoquer reconvoquer
reconvoque depuis qu'il a donné cette
habitude
c'est ce qui se passe maintenant vous
avez un conseil quasiment tous les mois
et demi et bien voilà typiquement nous
avons fait évoluer notre famille
politique l'europe
est-ce qu'on est moins européen non je
trouve paradoxal que ceux qui se disent
très européen surtout ne veulent rien
changer
ce sont eux les véritables ennemis de
l'europe ils veulent surtout une europe
qui ne change pas c'est à dire qu'ils
n'évoluent pas dans ces blocages jeu
nous ne sommes pas en cela eurobéats où
tout ce qui viendrait de l'europe serait
parfait non tout ce qui vient de
l'europe n'est pas parfait parce que la
construction de la gouvernance n'est pas
une construction n'est pas une bonne
construction
vous avez parlé des discours on parle
parfois de l'élargissement
l'élargissement qui a été fait jusqu à
il ya dix ans et la pologne à rentrer ya
dix ans n'est pas un problème en soi
l'élargissement vous pouvez pas me
laisser les gens dehors le problème en
revanche c'est qu'on a fait
l'élargissement avec les mêmes règles et
où vous aujourd'hui à 28 on a les mêmes
règles que ya 25 ans quand nous étions
12 ou 15
c'est ça le vrai sujet et donc c'est
pour ça que le machin aurait dit le
général de gaulle fonctionne si mal et
si lentement quand j'ai la parole au
parlement auberges et 60 secondes pour
répondre aux questions
j'en ai pris un peu plus je reviens
encore sur ce sujet il ya eu un sondage
hier qui montrait qu alain juppé était à
47 % soutenue en tout cas avec nous les
français avaient une opinion favorable
de lui laurent wauquiez 17% et xavier
bertrand 30%
finalement cette idée d'une sur une
suggestion de formation centrale que
estrosi à monsieur estrosi pardon à
appuyer ce matin ça peut-être pas parce
que c'est vraiment en danger par d'un
marine le pen par rapport aux français
ou plus pour l air pour les républicains
alors si vous regardez ce qui se passe
un peu en europe puisque nous sommes sur
cette thématique qui pour nous est
essentielle vous voyez qu'il ya une
poussée des populismes partout où la
gauche et la droite ont décidé ou de se
retirer ou de s'associer par tous sans
aucune exclusive
ce qui est important pour nous est la
dimension européenne est dans l'adn de
notre parti politique
et si vous avez la curiosité de regarder
les ateliers de la ''refondation'' vous
verrez que l'intégralité de nos
militants mettent également cet adn au
coeur de notre projet justement personne
chez nous ne veut pas de l'europe au
contraire posé la question de quelle
europe
c'est une autre question alors si on ne
peut plus poser de question qu'il faut
nous le dire
ils ne sont pas encore en marche
donc il faut à un moment clairement posé
cette question là après ce qu'a dit
alain juppé
c'est juste que nous partageons aussi
avoir un discours positif sur l'europe
mais c'est ce que nous attendions depuis
cinq ans monsieur hollande ayant été
dans l'incapacité de faire exister la
france dans le cadre européen
notre problème aujourd'hui c'est encore
une fois passer d'un discours de
communicants averti et talentueux à une
réalité et cette réalité
aujourd'hui nous n'y sommes pas et le
compte n'y est pas et philippe vous en a
donné quelques éclaircissements et nous
ne sommes pas dans une europe
incantatoire nous sommes dans une europe
que nous souhaitons vécu est vécu par
l'ensemble de nos concitoyens
donc ce n'est pas un enjeu pour notre
famille politique
et ce n'est pas en enjeu pour aucun des
candidats notre famille politique je
pense que c'est ça aussi qu'il faut bien
intégrer aujourd'hui je suis pas sûr que
monsieur castaner exactement les mêmes
positions sur l'europe que monsieur
edouard philippe mais après c'est un
point de vue très personnel
vous parlez de sondage c'est très bien
un sondage mais sauf que nous on va
donner la parole à nos militants c'est
ça le sujet on ne gouverne pas nous ne
gouvernons pas par sondage
nous avons des militants qui ont fait la
désignation pris la décision d'adhérer
qui paient une cotisation qui
participent à la vie d'un parti dans
leurs demandes qu'ils veulent comme
président ils choisiront ils ont le
choix ils en ont 3 tous les partis
politiques n'organise pas un choix aussi
au silver je crois justement sur la
présidence du parti sont pas d'accord
entre les candidats sur un débat les
modalités ariane tout à l'heure à la
haute autorité
mais est-ce que vous pouvez envisager
qui épate débat
du tout d'abord que des candidats soient
pas d'accord entre eux c'est assez banal
puisque c'est quand même le c'est pour
ça qu'on a des candidats différents ils
sont pas d'accord entre eux sur les tas
de sujets de forme et de fond
alors après il ya la question du débat
que vous posez nous sommes partis nous
n'avons rien à dire il ya des candidats
il ya une haute autorité donc aux
candidats de se mettre d'accord et à la
haute autorité de trancher sur un accord
quant à trouver les candidats mais le
parti lui va pas s'immiscer dans une
élection comme secret on voit le truc
gros comme une maison si nous commencer
à dire ce qu'il faut faire ou pas faire
on dira mais alors le truc n'est pas
libre ces deux partis qui n'ont il ya
une élection on a justement nous avons
voulu qu'elle soit la plus déconnectés
des intérêts immédiats du fonctionnement
du parti c'est pour ça qu'à une haute
autorité
sinon on aurait organisé à l'ancienne
nous même l'élection
mais encore une fois je ne peux que vous
répondre c'est aux candidats de donner
l'image qu'ils souhaitent donner et de
justifier ce qu'il leur décision comme
il souhaite la justifier chacun est
libre de sa campagne c'est pas nous qui
allons écrire la feuille de route d'un
candidat ou ça n'aurait aucun sens dans
ces cas là il faut aller en marchant là
vous avez la même feuille de route pour
tout le monde et c'est réglé le débat il
a lieu quasiment tous les soirs pour les
trois candidats sur les tous les
territoires qu'ils soient metropolit a
ou non ils font campagne
ils sont présents ils font des salles
donc voilà la campagne elle se vit elle
se vit sur le terrain alors je sais bien
que certains regrettent qu'elle survive
pas à paris mais les territoires c'est
aussi important
je passe la parole à madame le chevalier
alors il sauf que j étais je peux
peut-être en parler car c'est assez
drôle parce que en l'espace le oui
j'avais pu me libérer étonnamment le
parallèle avec alain juppé est assez bon
en fait il ya le contexte là
contextualisations et l'hyper
contextualisations revisité et en
l'espèce on est vraiment dans l'hyper
contextualisations revisiter mes hypra
revisité en plus donc ni dans le haut ni
dans le off
moi je n'ai entendu autre chose que la
famille doit être unie et elle doit
savoir tendre la main ce qui est dans
l'adn des trois candidats non mais
franchement
valérie et moi connaissons bien nicolas
sarkozy on a nous avons beaucoup
travaillé avec lui et ce qu'il a dit
c'est ce qu'il dit depuis toujours
depuis toujours il dit qu'il faut que le
parti soir ferme sur ces bases est
extrêmement ouvert il quand il avant
d'être président de la république c'est
ce qu'il a fait autant le parti quand il
était aux affaires c'est ce qu'il a fait
au gouvernement et si ce qui leur fait
quand il est venu au parti ici donc il
ya vraiment rien de nouveau mais c'est
vrai que l'hyper contractualisation
c'est tout à fait ça va et c'est
fondamental
effectivement c'est fondamental mais je
crois que tous les trois candidats sont
conscients de ça pour le coup on peut
leur faire crédit
merci infiniment à bientôt